for the men how many okay for girls at
10 how many points does it subtract a
kid so if she's a 10 with no kids how
many points does a kid subtract wow she
becomes a five five years hey Sarah what
about you a ten
from experience for each kid how much
does it subtract from experience I've
been with a woman who's had a child and
you could be a 10 you go down to at
least a six okay what about you so Four
Points what about you
um for me it would depend on whether
she'd allow me to parent as well and it
depend on like yeah okay okay well if
you don't want someone you know my Dad
yeah exactly
I'm just asking what how many 10 minus
how much
it would depend on the relationship I'd
only say one point one point
wait wait do we say one point because
you haven't experienced it yeah no I
will also say though the reason why you
both of you are saying what you're
saying is because you are with women who
didn't make space I'm not with a woman
separately with women who didn't make
the space for you to be a parent in that
situation as well and because you
weren't in that situation it was
terrible because you had no respect
which is what we've been speaking about
you want to be in a relationship bro but
can I say something
I'm not gonna lie
someone else is a woman a woman that's
not true calm down a woman who has a
child will let you know it's their job
yeah that's my point yeah
I'm saying a woman who has a child who
is theirs who with us consciously or
subconsciously let you know that's not
your child feel like if you date a
single I'm not sure I feel like if you
date a single mother as a guy you should
be able to cheat that's how I feel yeah
oh wow no no
I'll tell you why because his mating
strategy strategy is if we go back to
our biology right it's to screw as many
people as possible and ensure paternity
our our mating strategy is to get
resources from a guy so you get your
mating strata and and commitment from
the guy so you get your mating strategy
fulfilled and he has to deal with
someone else's kid nah like you cheated
on him by not waiting for marriage to
have a child
so so I I think you you basically
cheated on him by not giving him Purity
and youth I mean you can't give him
Purity you can't give him wait wait wait
you can't give him Purity if you have a
child you can't that's true and so it's
like if you don't offer that why would
you expect monogamy
let me rude
ladies ladies let me try and give you
some game yeah seriously you don't
understand the minds of men no they
don't they don't um
you're sitting with one two three I do
blessing over there four men and we're
trying to give you the minds of men you
are not listening to us
wait but wait but wait listen No but
wait but wait but wait I'm saying
meant value purity
and we value youth can I not say I wait
say like let me
let me speak
Purity and youth okay you can among
amongst your girls have whatever
conversation that you want to have
amongst your girls women live in an echo
chamber amongst their women all the time
oh yeah girl he's this yeah you can do
that all the time when you come out of
that Echo chamber and you speak to men
there's reality there you get the
reality and that's and wait you'll put
your hand down what I'm trying to say to
you is right when one of the main
problems in this Society is women do not
listen to when men speak and when men do
speak right they call them misogynistic
they call them all kinds of names that
they want to call them right but what
you're not listening to is
men are speaking and are telling their
truth
this is man's truth if you come to me
with a child two children three children
you are not our first choice
I'm telling you you don't have children
so it's cool you no man wakes up as you
if you talk about your Gotti is 41 years
old he did not wake up in the morning
thinking you know the woman that I
actually want to have for my long-term
partner is a widowed okay baby what is a
widowed baby mama that's my first choice
to be realistic but I'm saying nobody oh
my god seriously
generally men that is not their first
choice no it's not their first shot do
you think men wake up thinking they want
baby mamas as as their as their
long-term part what you're saying and
they don't want that so what I'm trying
to say to you is when you're a baby
mother you lose points so we are
settling for baby mamas if if a man has
a baby mama he's settling
I think a baby Mama does not need to be
that job
it doesn't matter what you think wait
wait wait wait listen to what I'm saying
my mom would change wait it doesn't
matter what you think no I'm I'm not
saying no wait it doesn't matter what
you think I think we're talking about
what men think we're not talking about
what you think and this man who wants my
mom my goodness gracious my dear woman
do you do you want to hang on wait wait
wait we as men understand the minds of
women we understand what women want
generally as yes we do we understand
that women trust me
anyone can say I want this and I want
that she actually doesn't want that
right so we understand that women want
General things we like to play you want
security do you want security of course
everyone okay do you want to protect her
of course do you want a provider of
course
protectors and providers and people who
do that we understand as men that's what
we've got to be the problem is as women
you don't understand what men want you
think you understand what men want and
the reason why you think you understand
what men want is because you live within
an echo chamber of your girlfriend true
you have not come out of that Echo
chamber and asked men what do you want
from us as women yeah so hang on when
women do
you say oh that's misogynistic no that's
just what men want so as men we can
actually understand this we can actually
Talk Amongst ourselves and say this is
what we are as men want but you think
because of your Echo chamber
that's misogynistic okay how many how
many
um dads are out there let's say I'm a
dad oh yeah Dad yeah I'm a dad too these
are that's lovely there you go shout out
to the kids so I've seen women that are
baby mums get with a guy that respects
his child her child
respects her and the whole situation way
more than the actual real baby that did
sorry say that again repeat that what
I'm trying to say is that I've seen
women that have kids dating guys she's
obviously like separated divorce
whatever she's dating other guys and
Dave actually and they've respected this
yes way more than maybe their own dad
has yeah but respect
do you know what because he's a good guy
do you know why why I'll blame the girl
because she was with the wrong guy in
the first place okay I hear it but what
I'm trying to say is that like it don't
it does to say that not every guy thing
thinks that you know because she's got a
child
it's because he doesn't have any other
options it's because his pickings
weren't that good honestly there's four
like one there's 41 forms of birth
control like why are you getting
pregnant with like maybe with this
random like I don't understand why these
girls are getting babies left and right
41 forms of birth control yeah but you
can be married get and have a kid that
doesn't mean okay but then but then you
have a duty don't leave what'd you mean
don't leave women women leave it women
leave
um 70 of the time if they're college
educated they leave 90 of the time
correct women ruin relationships and
they ruin families women women typically
do it actually if a guy ask the majority
of men their first choice is not a baby
mother just like just like our first
choice typically is not a short broke
guy that's right it's the same thing
it's the same thing now now will we put
up with a guy that's shorter if he's
good looking sure well will a guy put up
with a single mother if she has some
other things that she brings to the
table maybe she's attractive maybe she
has other stuff maybe she's submissive
whatever it is that he values yeah but
it's most men it is not their first
choice okay but maybe that woman that
has the child has more to offer than a
woman that doesn't and you're talking as
a woman you don't see him
what you just said is an example of
simping and that's exactly what we've
been talking about discussed today if a
guy would go out of his way to give more
to a woman who already has a child he's
doing that because he knows that if he
wants to be with a woman he's actually
got to show respect for the child 100 so
he has to simp actually he's got to do
more he's got to give more to be in that
relationship right and this this is what
this is why we're here talking about it
it's not it's not just effort because
she's she's not gonna have to do that
for him
like when you're when you're a single
mother and you get married you get all
the benefits and he had so so it's like
we we get bailed out of a bad decision
like you made a poor choice and instead
of taking your bed and lying in it you
get bailed out by some sense why do you
have to lie in a bed that maybe is very
harmful for yourself though because you
made it poor twice I've been in a
relationship as well yeah single like
where the the girl has a baby they don't
let you attack some some girls they
don't let you meet their babies that's
right something is and you can't
discipline no anyone yeah
let me speak first of all you don't you
you don't get to see the child you don't
get to sit down with them and until
things are serious
and clear to her that you that you're
showing intention you're so intention
right so uh so for me as a man if you
let me understand from the beginning
okay I have a child but first of all I'm
not gonna let you meet my child for the
first six months that we're dating
their dad or his dad or her dad comes
around every now and then to check to to
check on them so you have to respect
that right if she makes everything clear
to you from the beginning right and you
have feelings for her despite her having
a child I don't condemn that right you
can be with a with a single mother and
build a family yeah with alongside that
that child has been there already right
there's nothing wrong with that yeah
yeah there's there's nothing wrong with
it it's like an adult situation no but
but then for a man no but then I'll get
to a point right yeah sorry if if like
there's no problem dating or Mariners
single woman a single mother right yeah
but uh but but there's this situation
where
this is you you you made me lose
but then but then what's sorry saying as
a man we don't put as a single mother as
our first choice of course it's not your
first choice if you have kids yourself
oh yes you you cannot go and tell people
if they can and can't happen but let me
finish earlier you were saying that you
don't put a virgin guy as your first
choice to have sex with
I'll say the same thing and it's not
controversial and the men won't get
upset a single father isn't my first
choice right most women most women don't
care because because the thing is like
when a man has multiple children it
signals to to most women that other
women have selected him and like
actually I've heard from single dads
that they get more women after they have
kids so I'm not the norm but I I can
I've said on this plot podcast multiple
times single father not my first choice
and it's not controversial but like
women get triggered I don't know why no
but a fingers
I'm a father and I understand
so many times I don't care I have a
child and I understand I'm not woman's
First Choice I'm and I'm cool with me I
understand can I say something no no no
wait let me finish though
I'm a single father and I understand
that I'm not a woman it's real because
I've got a child and I may have quote
unquote baggage that I'm bringing With
Me true when you say that to a woman ah
yo but hang on but why don't you
understand the same thing that's that's
the selfishness
don't go to say that um a woman that has
a child is less valuable in your eyes a
woman that has a child is less valuable
to a man wait wait wait wait not to not
to herself and not to her girlfriends
yeah and that's what I said women need
to step out of their Echo Chambers and
start asking men hang on as many of you
know I was just banned on Tic Tac and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible